yeah justice is a kind of drug
so if you look at history also been
reading a lot about stalin
i mean all those folks really
i don't know i don't know what was
inside hitler's head actually that he's
a tricky one
because i think he was legitimately
insane stalin was not
and stalin was like he literally thought
he's doing a good thing
he literally thought for the entirety of
the time
that communism is going to bring like
that's the utopia
and is going to create a happy world
and in his in his mind were
ideas of justice of
fairness of happiness of of uh
yeah human flourishing and that's that's
a drug
and it somehow sadly pollutes the mind
when you start thinking like that
what's good for society and believing
that
you have a good sense of what's good for
society
that's intoxicating especially when
others around you are feeling the same
way
and then you start like building up this
movement and you forget
that you were just like a you're you're
like
barely recently evolved from an ape like
you don't know what the hell you're
doing
and then you start like killing witches
or whatever like you start
you start doing they did math let's be
honest though i mean sometimes you got a
witch has to go
yeah we can all agree there which which
has to go if
if it floats or sinks which one i forget
which which
whichever one we need at the time
honestly it's floating it should have
sunk
uh yeah but yeah we can definitely agree
that we just have to go
you